the Rachel Dolezal case and phenomenon
is interesting part of me finds it very
silly people have been talking about
this idea of transracial like if one
comparing her to Caitlyn Jenner and
saying you know if someone can choose
can say that they were born feeling a
woman or born feeling a man in a woman's
body or what have you then if they can
make that choice shouldn't someone still
be able to make that choice around race
I would push back and say that I don't
think that those are the same thing I
think those have very different
consequences and implications and
manifest themselves in very different
ways and you know Rachel Dolezal you
know while she might deeply love black
culture my while she might deeply
believed herself to be a participant in
black social and cultural spaces at the
end of the day she can opt out you know
she can say she she can choose to not be
black in a way that black people cannot
choose to not be black I can't you know
get pulled over by policemen and tell
him you know I'm white today so the way
you should interact with me as a white
person because that's how identify I
can't do that that's not a reality I
don't have the opportunity to or the
would ever want to opt in or out of my
racial identity for Rachel Dolezal she
she can she can choose if it if it came
down to a matter of deep inconvenience
she could choose to not navigate the
world as a black person anymore and in
the implications of her her actions are
subsequently very different than in a
real black woman's I think it brings up
a larger conversation around what is
race which i think is an important
conversation have because again we have
to recognize that race is largely a
social construct like it is not an
actual real thing racism and and because
race hill has been made a real
historical issue those things are real
but what it's done
I think in what's important is it is
served as a catalyst for a dialogue
again in a different way as so many
things over the course of this year have
around what race is how we think about
it how we conceive of what it means to
be racialized and I think these are
important conversations to have